i'm going to show you a number sequence
which is better than the fibonacci
sequence and i know i mean i always say
something is better than the fibonacci
sequence because i don't really like it
but
in this case this is something that is
similar but it uses a different rule so
the fibonacci just to remind everyone
you had one plus one that gives you two
you have one plus two that gives you
three and each time what you're doing is
you're taking the previous two
and then that gives you the next one
five then you take those two and that
gives you the next one eight then you
take those two and that gives you the
next one thirteen times i'm adding them
in pairs i'm gonna do exactly the same
thing
but instead of just adding them i'm also
going to copy the last one so if i start
one one
right so i'm going to add 1 plus 1 and
that gives me 2. then i'm going to copy
the last one which is a 1. okay the next
pair is 1 2. add them you get 3 i'm
going to copy the last one which is a 2.
okay now it's 2 1. if i add them i get
another 3. the last one is a one
okay one three add them i get a four the
last one is a three okay three two add
them i get a five the last one is a two
okay two and if i carry on like this
there's another five last one is a three
i keep going so this beast grows quicker
than you can keep up with it which is
amazing right so with the fibonacci
you're always at the end as you go along
this one's great because as you're
copying it the bit you're working on
like the end of it's racing away from
you and so i like that and it's got a
kind of syncopated kind of beat that's
how i feel because because you're not
always adding you're doing a bit of this
and that and so it's not moving at a
regular rate well you're writing one at
a time anyway so i like it as a sequence
i think it's more interesting to
generate and it
requires a bit more concentration than
just copying out the fibonacci numbers
and you get these unusual numbers uh
this is called the stern
brocot
sequence or the sternbroke numbers you
might think well what what's so
wonderful about why would we want these
and so what you do now is you go back to
the beginning of the sternbroker numbers
and you take them in pairs to form a
fraction so that first one let's call
that uh actually let's mix it up with
colors let's go one
okay so let's take the first one as a
fraction that's that that is one over
one the next one is a fraction is one
over two so i'm taking the numerator
denominator numeric denominator all the
way down in pairs next one's two on one
next one's one on three
three on two
two on three
three on one and what will happen i'm up
to one on four if i carry that on
this will list out
every possible fraction this will list
every single ratio of whole numbers not
only that it will always list them in
their most simplified form and it will
only ever list them once each
that's cool
so nowhere no fraction will appear twice
and no fraction will appear not as
simple as it can be and none will be
missed so this sequence gives you every
single rational number in existence
there are reasons why we want to list
out and order all the rational numbers
and actually one of the early number
file videos infinity is bigger than you
think by the fine doctor james grime
in godel's proof that the rationals are
the same size as the reals it's a video
worth watching he uses a grid and the
grid unfortunately hugely inefficient
because numbers appear in there more
than once they appear and they're not in
the most simplified form so you get a
half you also get two fourths you get
four eights in the rest whereas here
there's a half
no other fraction will ever appear
which equals a half you get each one
once and once only this is really
efficient and uh this came out
in a paper called recounting the
rationals so it was another way of
counting the rationals and they come up
with this fantastic sequence which then
generates those fractions
but
it's not the only way to do it again
there's another way to generate every
possible fraction without repeating them
and they always appear in the most
simplified form and what you do for that
start with the most simple fraction
known to humankind which is one over one
now we're going to have two children are
going to come off this fraction and one
of them is going to inherit the top and
one's going to
inherit the bottom and the missing
number is going to be the sum of the
numerator and the denominator that's
going to be a half and that's going to
be two ones and then each of those are
going to have
kids that one's going to inherit the top
that one's going to inherit the bottom
and that is the sum and that is the sum
that one inherits the top this one in
here it's the bottom that's the sum
that's the sun what you can see here we
are actually generating here we go again
let's do another i'm this is getting a
little bit bunched up i'll try and even
it out that one gets the top this one
gets the bottom that one gets the top
this one gets the bottom that one gets
the top this one gets the bottom that
one gets the top this one gets the
bottom that is the sum there and there
that is the sum there and there and
there is the sum
there and then there and then there and
then this process
as you work your way
uh down we'll again list out every
single fraction it will list them all in
the most simplified form and it will not
have any repeats and you think well how
am i going to read them off well if you
take a spiral so we're going to start at
1 1 and then we're going to go a half
and then
two on one and then we're going to go
through these and then we're going to go
through those and if you take the
sequence along that spiral it goes one
on one
it's over here there goes a half then
goes two on one then goes a third then
goes three twos two thirds three on one
one quarter and then it carries on so
this is generating exactly the same
series of fractions that we got from the
stern brocot sequence in fact you could
start with this and then you could go
back to those numbers if you lined up
all the fractions you'd find they pair
up all the way along cancel remove the
doubles and you get back to the original
sequence
there are links to more from this
interview and other videos on the topic
here on the screen if you'd like to know
even more from matt you can also check
out his book things to make and do in
the fourth dimension which was recently
released in fact it's only just out in
the us as i upload this i will put a
bunch of links in the video description
it's a really good book plus a really
good way to throw your support behind
matt so from this sequence i know there
are three ways
to write six in binary
if you're allowed to use twos as well
and if you just love the way matt looks
and why wouldn't you he's also depicted
on the new number file poster i'll also
pop a link to that in the video
description